flying into this country i mean
why not not a travel ban just
mandatory testing we have gone
through this just test all international
travelers before
entry tell the airlines you have to test
them before they get on a plane to come
to this country
or say if you land in this country we're
not going to allow you
in until you take a test
140 countries
banned or required testing of uk
travelers before the united states acted
140 countries
new york acted before the united states
i called the airlines and i said i want
new york to be added to the 140
countries
and they headed new york to the 140
countries
what's really infuriating
this is what happened to us in last
spring
learn the lesson the virus left
china the virus went to europe it was in
italy
it was in the uk people got on a plane
came to new york
and that's why new york had the
explosion that's what i call the coveted
ambush
we've learned nothing so now there's a
second strain
and it came from the uk again
and again the usa did absolutely nothing
secretary azar dr redfield
how you can explain to the american
people
your lack of action your negligence
your irresponsibility 140 countries
banned people from the uk and you did
nothing
you know that there are viral strains in
other
countries now you know that is a fact
why wouldn't you mandate testing
how many times do you have to learn the
same lesson over and over what happened
to
competent leadership in government
the usa must act if the united states
won't act
then new york state will act but i can't
allow people
to fly into this state who we know
are coming from countries that have
other viral strains
new york loves being the gateway we
welcome people from all across the globe
we are on the eastern seaboard that's
always been our role
that's how we all wound up here we
celebrate it
but to allow the virus
to be landing at our airports
and to make new york a petri dish and
the federal government does
nothing i can't allow that to happen
i wouldn't be doing my job as governor
of the state of new york
let's take some questions
thank you governor if you would like to
ask a question please use the raise hand
function at the bottom of your window
we'll take a brief moment to compile the
q a roster
governor your first question comes from
jeff cole of wwny
jeff your line is now open please um
your microphone
uh governor good morning you can hear me
okay i can hear you jeff how are we
doing
not bad hello from watertown uh there's
a lot of covet data online and when it
comes to
hospitals and how many doses that they
have been given and how many that they
have used
there's a deadline that you set is new
york going to require this information
to be reported and posted online we're
finding that some hospitals don't want
to be very transparent with that
yeah this is a little bit of a work in
progress we posted online
uh when i don't i don't know if we did
it i guess we consider it online we
released yesterday
the 10 fastest and the 10
slowest
and its department of health data
that they confirmed uh
by the way they're embarrassed
some hospitals that were slow performers
it wound up showing some hospitals that
were performing very well
and the ones who were performing very
well were happy and the ones who were
shown to be slow
were upset but
life is about accountability
some of the hospital management said
in defense things that were not true
the data that was reported
was not for allocations they had just
received it was from
allocations they had received over the
first
two weeks and not the most recent
allocation
so they were slow in
in distributing older allocations
also you have some hospitals who have
only done
half their workforce
now we've only had enough allocation for
half
of the workforce the healthcare
workforce
but some have only done half the
workforce
we have to do better than vaccinating
half of our health care workers if a
hospital says
only half of their employees will take
the vaccine
we have a problem critical mass on this
vaccine
is 70 to 90 percent
uh health care workers who are the most
informed
i don't think it's it's
possible or credible that only half of
them will take the vaccine
i have also been deluged with phone
calls
of health care workers saying
i can't get a vaccine and i'm going out
there
every day and i haven't gotten a vaccine
so it's a combination of
slow hospitals
and we've only had
half the allocation for the health care
workers from the federal government
now when i talk about slow hospitals
i have greatest respect for nurses and
doctors
i'm sure they're all doing everything
they can and they've done a fantastic
job
it's the leadership that i'm talking
about
you know the uh the
nation at war and the army keeps losing
president calls and fires the general
it's not a comment on the soldiers
soldiers are killing themselves
the general gets fired end of the losing
football season
it's the coach that gets fired
it's about the leadership so it's
nothing about the nurses and the doctors
it's about the leadership it's about the
management
always is and that's taking
responsibility and accountability
we have we'll continue to release the
high and the low performers
but i don't know that the data is
uh ready to a place where we could
distribute it widely is that fair enough
yeah then as the governor said we have
636 providers who have enrolled this
number is growing
who are currently getting the vaccine
this number is going to grow it's
important that you know they
are aware of what data they need to
submit they're submitting it timely in
an accurate manner
until you know we can work through that
with them and as governor said we our
plan is to have a public dashboard as
soon as we can we want to make sure the
information we're putting out there
everyone can rely on yeah
and just to be clear the uh
the figures that we used yesterday were
for the first three weeks of allocation
we're in the fourth week we did not
include this week's allocation
this is from the preceding week one
week two week three so
if they want to complain about
accountability know your facts
and facts are facts i think
hospitals shouldn't complain about the
transparency
because if you're doing your job then
what are you worried about and if you're
not doing your job
with a vaccine that could be the matter
of life and death
then people have a right to know
next question operator thank you
governor
you now have keisha clucky from
bloomberg
keisha your lime is now open please
unmute your microphone
hi governor thanks for taking my uh
question
um if you don't mind just a twofold in
there why
are the hospitals so slow is it possible
that they
maybe were over allocated vaccines and
then also
what's the legal ramification or legal
side to finding the hospitals um
particularly public hospitals as well
uh your if you find the public hospital
systems wouldn't that just hurt the
state
um in terms of funding thank you yeah
uh on the hospitals
1a 1a is
hospital healthcare workers
using the hospitals to distribute to
health care workers
makes eminent sense as i mentioned we
also have
600 other places in the state
retail outlets 600 other retail outlets
where health care workers can go now to
receive the vaccine
but it was primarily through the st
through the hospitals
because that's where the healthcare
workers are many of them have done a
great job
some of them are slow uh some have been
at 99 percent some of them are at
15 percent whatever was on the bottom
so there's a very wide spectrum
uh were they over allocated no
because our allocation is
we've only received enough vaccine for
half of the health care workers
we've only received enough vaccine for
half of the health care workers
so no we don't have enough vaccine
to go to all health care workers then
why are they slow
a variety of reasons you know these are
194 hospitals
some of them frankly operate better than
others
it's like anything else in life you know
you take 194 barber shops
some are going to operate better than
others you take 194 government agencies
some are going to operate better than
others you take 194 city
governments some mayors are better than
others
you know you take 50 states some
governors are better than others it's
it's the marketplace it's human nature
uh they have a whole host of reasons you
know um
but we can't
we have to we have to vaccinate the
healthcare workers
now again the
we have 194 hospitals
if a hospital doesn't do it well
that's fine but then i want to use a
hospital
that does do it well uh
let me take a step back we have two
issues for the hospitals that now have
the vaccine
i need them to get that vaccine in
people's arms
and if they don't do that they can get
fined
or we can retrieve the allocation
retrieving the allocation is a problem
because this is refrigerated it's not
easy to transport
so for those hospitals that have it
already
use it or lose it you won't get any more
and you can be fined going forward
we just won't use those hospitals again
there are other hospitals use the
hospitals that are better
at administration and
are faster and more efficient at doing
the job we have 194 hospitals we don't
have to use
every hospital and we're going to have
thousands of retail centers so
we want to use the hospitals that are
better at doing it
and i've spoken to dozens of hospitals
it's it's a function
of that hospital you know you have
hospitals where they've only done
half their employees after four weeks
you know how do you explain that well
the other half wouldn't take it
that would be a real debacle
but we didn't have a chance to do it you
know
dr zucker is the great defender of the
hospitals
being as he's the doctor so i'll ask him
for his rationale
i i think the governor has nailed all
the key points here
the hospital systems i've spoken to
several hospital
ceos um they need to be aggressive and
they recognize this
um some are just more efficient at
moving things forward
um i think that um they will uh they'll
push forward to get all those vaccines
in
employees arms and i remain optimistic
about that
and look the your point about
the fine
this is not about money this is about
saving lives
we're not really interested in
collecting fines
we're really interested in for those
hospitals
who now have the allocation and are slow
move the allocation move it quickly
we're serious and
[Music]
if you don't want to be fined just
don't participate in the program
uh it's not a mandatory
program we don't have to have all 194
hospitals
just say i don't want to do it that's
fine
uh we have plenty of hospitals and i'd
rather use the better
performing hospitals
the situation we're in is we've already
allocated
to all the hospitals and again as i said
before it's hard to get it back
but if a hospital calls up and says
i'm going to use this allocation and
then i want out
fine that's totally fine
next question thank you governor
you now have emily burkhardt of wnyt
emily your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
hi governor i was curious if you could
tell us a little bit more about whether
or not
wadsworth has been able to determine if
the other cases found at the jewelry
store
in saratoga are in fact a result of the
uk strain and i'm also curious if the
state department of health
is stepping in with contact tracing
we've reported on issues in saratoga
county before
and now that this strain is supposedly
more transmissible is the state stepping
in to help with that
all good questions we're going to turn
them right over to the commissioner
of the department of health since
they're all specifically department of
health questions
thank you with regards to the contract
tracing we're doing aggressive contact
tracing
of all of those who were were in the
store this is uh
has been taking place since the minute
we learned about this regarding the
issue of the
testing and do we have any further
information it takes
44 hours or so to do the actual genome
testing
so we learned about this yesterday we
got the samples uh yesterday and we are
doing this
as soon as we have answers we can
provide that i will note that
we do this a lot quicker a lot more
efficiently
than the federal government the cdc
takes a lot longer than that
and other states have reported as take
several weeks to get results back
from the federal government so we're
moving very quickly on this uh regarding
the samples that have come
to see whether the other individuals had
the uk strain or have the uk strain
thank you actually it's a very involved
test
for this uk strain it takes the cdc two
weeks to do a test
it takes wadsworth uh about 40 hours to
do a test
as you know the normal covet test is
very quick so it is a complicated
uh situation and again just to make sure
i was clear on the hospitals
the we had distributed to all hospitals
uh in the state uh going forward we'll
just distribute it
to the hospitals that do a better job
because we'll have other options also
but in the meantime for those hospitals
that already have the allocation
get it out get it out get it out
question
operators think a new question
next question comes from peter haskell
wcbs radio
peter your line is now open please don't
meet your microphone
hey governor i i've got questions about
these retail sites so a a few of them
quickly to have the staff
to cover all these sites
when do you expect they'll open and then
how do people
sign up people hear they're gonna have
this opportunity
where do they go how do they do it do
they need to prove they're
eligible an essential worker or
otherwise
and should we expect to see lines like
we've seen in other places
okay uh good to hear your voice peter
the we're not there yet
first of all uh we're getting 300
000 vaccines right now a week
we've distributed 900 000
vaccines for a 2 million
population of health care workers
obviously to get through health care
workers if you're doing
three hundred thousand per week
you need another four weeks
of allocation before you can get out of
health care workers
roughly roughly before you finish 1a and
you move to 1b
1b opens essential workers
and general public over 75 years old
the could you move a little faster
from health care workers
look if you have a hospital now that
says
i did all my health care workers
and i have an extra allocation contact
us
and we'll move it
it would be a very bad sign
if a hospital said only half of my
health care workers
will take the vaccine obviously
that's a bad sign for the overall
effectiveness
of the herd immunity program which is 70
to 90 percent
and also i don't believe it i don't
believe a hospital
that says only half my workers will take
it
uh i can tell you i'm deluged with phone
calls from health care workers
who are saying i want the vaccine i
can't get it
we expect about
a 70 percent acceptance rate of the
vaccine
federal officials will say 70 to 90. i
don't think you ever get near 90.
i think if i was offering to give away
cash
to new yorkers i don't think we'd have a
90 acceptance rate
so uh but a 30
refusal uh 25 percent refusal
is what we expect to see from the health
care community
but not 50 percent
[Music]
so uh the
retail component is this
every year you do the flu vaccine
who administers the flu vaccine
the private market
administers the flu vaccine roughly half
the people in the state take the flu
vaccine
and it's very little government
involvement
there's a whole private market that can
distribute vaccines we now have today
peter
in new york city 200
retail outlets for you to get a
vaccine uh
just check that number 207
in new york city 207 i know you're
specific peter if i said 200 it was 207
207 retail outlets today
in new york city where you can get a
vaccine
if you are eligible now
you'd have to go there and prove that
you are a healthcare worker
uh ems emt doctor nurse etc
and you have to show proof of that at
that facility
um next tranche
the essential workers
what i'm asking today is
as many essential workers police
fire teachers transit workers
as many of them as can use their own
networks that would be great
their own networks meaning either their
employees can vaccinate
uh that unit
police have ems emt fire department
fire department can vaccinate police etc
teachers have a health care network
transit workers have a health care
network
as many of them that can handle it
themselves great
otherwise we have the retail
system the retail system will be
hospitals
will be pharmacies
five thousand pharmacies in the state
just the way you do a flu
vaccine will be federally qualified
health centers
will be urgent care centers
will be local health departments and
when you get to the general
population it's easier peter because the
main criteria is going to be your age
so your license would do it
right there are many uh pieces of id
that can
actually document your age
um but again this is down the road but
that retail system
uh has been used in the past we've been
using it now to do the covet testing
right uh so we'll implement that
and then we'll have supplemental efforts
as we did with kova testing
state-sponsored drive-through sites
javit center will operationalize
and then special outreach to
black latino and poor communities
so that's where we are let's take one
more
thank you governor your final question
comes from michael gormley of newsday
michael your line is now open please
unmute your microphone
hello governor on the the
health care workers are refusing to to
get the vaccine can't you
can't you direct them to do that and i
believe that some health care workers
are already required to get the
the flu vaccine every year and then it
just doesn't decide to that if i can
if you could allow us to resume having
follow-up questions
that might be helpful for the public and
for you i know that you've had some
you wanted us to clarify some of our
questions in the past and
we weren't able to talk to you thank you
thank you michael the
we have not crossed the bridge to say by
law you must take it
uh yes
well there is a legal question
as to whether or not with what's called
an emergency authorization
you can man this is an emergency
authorization
federal approval there is a
complicated legal question as to whether
or not you can
mandate a person take
and a vaccine that is
authorized as an emergency authorization
but besides the legal question we
haven't gotten there yet because i don't
know
that it is going to be an issue
you're right we went through this with
measles
uh but i don't know and
you're right you have a legal argument
especially with healthcare employees
that you could say to a healthcare
employee
you um
you need to take the vaccine as a part
of your job
we're not there yet i don't i don't
believe the refusal rate
is going to be that high
i think doctors get it
but beth can speak to the legal question
about the emergency authorization use
yes governor that's correct so with an
emergency
use authorization as these vaccines have
there are
more complicated questions especially
for those in vulnerable
population groups that have not been
studied as part of these clinical trials
but we will
continue to look at it and we will
continue to monitor
okay anyone have anything else additions
deletions omissions
commissions thank you very much have a
nice day
foreign
you